how's the gum rest the names waterful
welcome back to daylight in the last
episode we managed to not die horribly I
get the feeling that's gonna happen to
this one
hello closed fix this game is it all
about the glow sticks unless you have
too many glow sticks ACCA's and partly
that's a thing well what can you do you
can't have everything in life can you
nice night at approximately 7:00 p.m.
the power went off due to this action
fertility unfortunate timing in the
mornings gone you can't go on as button
this is simply working what kind of [ __ ]
bud misses hello someone out there now
is it I just saved we understand that
it's difficult to make it outside on
your 10-minute breaks but be advised
it's not a gem equipment okay I'm sorry
I just think reading notes text away the
immersion from what I'm doing you can be
in marching notes too if you want no job
love is so I'll speak talk it where is
it going why is it going where is it
going where is it going
why does it go with I know nobody's no
one a chocolate though supply boys job
but wait the wit sorry I'm sorry
okay okay so that is this I didn't tell
you bros cuz I didn't wanna like I I
know Sarah I know Todd this is really
[ __ ] [ __ ] up [ __ ] but I need you to
pull your [ __ ] together you have an iPad
just think your focus on that iPad
okay there's shadow people and I don't
think they're nice people I'm nice I
understand why it would be mean
luckily um they're scared of flares
guess how many Flyers I have none
we're so [ __ ] I'm sorry I
I just I just want to warn you Kipling's
Edison's occurs crimes sixteen years old
girl love live admits kills estimator
condemned to an evil ass pita open the
deal we spread disease I'll spit again I
think I could be a new Oprah hello
okay I can hear you now this is this bad
what is that sound hello what is what
what is that
don't do that
Oh Megan Cox Megan Fox I stopped doing
that place a lot of things a lot of
things some objects can be climbed
awesome
can you be climbed I am climbing this um
no they can't touch me now so why did I
climb this boxes with the robes can be
moved all right maybe we can climb up
like this yes I can Jane yes all right
I'm gonna die now though sorry Sarah oh
you're fine I knew that I care about you
Sam oh god what did i do what did I do
yes what why why why
please tell me I would love to know it's
because my glow sticks doesn't work yes
that must be at my clothes it doesn't
work into that
yeah that's not it I mean there can be
anything else pageanty okay it's nothing
bad about not liking not being in the
duct I think I saw some boxes basis
there we are all right so what are we
gonna climb then we're gonna go back
maybe hmm that is the question it's C oh
I see it
I saw it before you Sun do-do-do-do
detective but I mad about bat-belt
you mean serah's gonna make it out of
here alive probably not be hey what are
you gonna do about it
alright I like this place it makes me
feel safe I don't know why maybe it's
all the boxes I like this makes me feel
good inside
who doesn't love a box you don't know
what's inside could be anything usually
good things they don't really put ice
cream in boxes though or do they
okay wait are we back here so we just
turn on the lights
maybe the button works now yes genius
yes oh my god if there's a president of
genius award somewhere then I mean
that's that's that wasn't that smart
that was pretty obvious but what I got
doesn't mean I can be awarded
hi everyone needs a confidence boost
every once in a while and I kind of need
one right now saving thank Jesus okay
let's keep I don't want to play anymore
let's just keep trying I guess oh oh
this [ __ ] noises man I can't I'm
sorry I can't I need a glow stick to
make myself feel better
ah it doesn't help it just makes a
creepier Oh what the [ __ ] is that get it
what what oh I I was thinking about how
great it would be if I would just to
leave this place and never come back
I'm actually a big fan of that idea the
suffer beer and
poor girl Jesus Christ I say I think I
don't I don't
Oh what was that what was that what was
that doctor okay there was nothing I'm
sure it's fine hi I got a little ahead
of myself some time and
ah maybe they're having a sawing contest
and they were really excited about
winning a yes that must be it
all right miss stinking Gary now I need
the burly room
I keep hearing things moving around down
there and then while I'm cleaning I
swear this ain't right something bigger
keep an eye out while you're down there
keep this game built so much tension oh
that's a hell it bet that you like get
it my kick your space next time you
[ __ ] Bureau so it seems that the game
is random which is pretty cool
I never realized that the game just
keeps amazing me actually that's pretty
amazing actually all right it's check in
here
these [ __ ] shadow people are the
worst kind of people man it sounds like
slimeballs is having fun here so I'm
gonna check it out okay that end all
right looks like we're gonna have to
either go down or go up here's the thing
though going down is creepy as [ __ ] cuz
just look at that [ __ ] going up you just
know you're gonna die so I'm going with
a creepy option thank you very much I
know what I'm doing it's okay I don't
even know there was a witch floor I'm on
how far okay the stairs end here so it
seems that this place I've quite a
leakage I'm opening Photoshop for some
reason okay what was that what was that
oh Jesus
it's fine and no party like I put up my
part am i right I'm all right
what what what did I do you don't like
point of pop art is okay now you just
can go Jesus Christ
Oh [ __ ] shadows Oh God Fisher the
blood the blood the blood go stick
Oh
what has happened
I don't want to pay you anymore oh I
just wanna be friends forever with the
boat
I can't even hide
I don't have flares I'm inside off for
this [ __ ] I really [ __ ] ban it play
we're organs poets it's fun
yeah well out for me okay those kept
legs and [ __ ] hey kept links go six
thought oh god what is in here like a
pancake container hello oh oh oh no oh
no oh no oh no oh no oh no I don't know
where to go I can go there hey let's
just go there what the [ __ ] is that what
the [ __ ] are you
stop following me I'm really nice oh oh
oh oh Jesus cries I don't know what not
what the hell oh god it's coming it's
coming it's coming
oh god what the hell can't you give them
a pill to break I need him okay wait
what am i doing in here what am i doing
in here what am i doing in here
oh you were so [ __ ] man you are so
[ __ ] man you are so [ __ ]
goddammit stop having saw in context I
think the side contest is coming closer
it's just a [ __ ] game holy [ __ ] the
other man okay
Jesus Christ
jesus [ __ ] christ Sarah god damn man
I can barely see why use your glow stick
power I don't talk it out
what what what shut up shut the [ __ ] up
all right this floor has been great so
good so good can't wait to never come
back I disguise what's with this
whispering okay I found another
progression point I just need to find
the teddy bear again all right cool
we can do this we can it it it's fine no
big down no big Dan all right I have to
end the episode there this game is
really terrifying like it's been in such
a long time since I really don't feel
like playing board because this is too
much
so yeah leaving that let me know if you
enjoy this and one more I'll I'll pull
my [ __ ] together and I'll get more leave
like if you do and then it's a scratch
on worth today I see brothers in the
next one
love you brother mom